we go through like butter man I took an
entire semester on heat transfer take a
class on heat transfer do transfer so
much heat we have at least one shoot
maybe two shoots coming up where we're
gonna need it first person ring we've
got this black magic micro Cinema Camera
it's so small it's so light it looks way
better than a GoPro I'm gonna be
mounting this up to a first person rig I
don't have much of a plan but all I know
is that we got all these little arms and
stuff I can screw them into the camera
I'm just going to see where this goes we
have a lot of gear and a lot of stuff
that's nice and organized now and
hopefully I'll dig through and find what
I need
[Music]
just got it I just need a little bit of
tape okay cool looks like it actually
fits great you just kind of like
counterweighted Nikko is talking about
making a mouth mount that you hold on to
us right like another point of
stabilization yeah I definitely need the
counterweight it's pulling this down and
pulling this up yeah
v1 pretty crappy but totally works you
wanna trade lenses real quick yeah I got
a wide angle lens on here it's so much
heavier this is definitely better
functions at the moment which is good I
was at the flea market the other day as
people were selling these coins and it's
this like old silver Mexican peso from
1882 I looked it up on eBay and these
things are selling and the really
interesting part about this coin is that
it's fake weight so you got Duke they
swindled me boys it not real silver so I
think it's plated silver first test you
can do is the magnet test
oh is that easy the cooler test to do
though
literally cooler is the IceCube test
this is real silver certified so we're
going to put an ice cube on the fake
coin if an ice cube on the real silver
coin and they're just nice keep on the
pan also exactly three two one
whoa look at that whoa dude that's crazy
the fake ones that it's barely melting
so even if it is plated I don't think it
probably conducts very much heat tips I
gotta go oh it just cuts right through
cut it on the silver yeah this is a
little silver it's crazy it's like it
feels like butter butter this is the
fake coin nope he's not even close
our friend audie Shankar has offered us
the introductory scene to the first
episode of his digital series called
gods and secrets so we are putting
together the final pieces of
pre-production for that which is
shooting on Friday today's Wednesday
I've got gay here working on some props
putting together some crazy creative
pieces that are going to sort of blend
the alternate reality 1950s era 1960s
era stuff with a little bit of sci-fi
I've got Bret and Sherwin out picking up
a bunch of art from a military supply
company they're going to come back with
a bunch of wooden crates and camo nets
and ammo boxes and a bunch of stuff
that's of that era gums from ebike
because you don't have enough you guys
are interested in purchasing an airsoft
gun of any kind you buy comm check them
out
kristan the costumers are going to come
by with a bunch of World War 2 costumes
that she picked up from Eastern costume
company we're gonna check those out
we're gonna pair them together with some
of the stuff that we've already been
building out and then get the actual
uniforms per character going it's always
important when you're building out
costumes and props that you start with
what you have and then you go out and
get sort of what you need put it all
together
voila you got yourself mm-hmm
yeah Adi I know I know man I'll make
sure that that the air conditioning is
at 71 degrees okay great so we're just
pushing it through ice like that
I thought ice is solid there's another
part of the story so you're grabbing
lunch afterwards with some friends and I
showed him the bar I'm like well I found
this coin I think it's silver he's like
how much is it worth I looked it up on
eBay hundreds of dollars Wow I'm like
wow I get home I researched the coin did
these tests find out that's for sure
fake texture I'm like well it turns out
the coins fake she's like what my friend
went back and he bought $70 worth of
coins and I'll just like cringed really
hard and we still been telling
oh man I hope he doesn't watch the same
Neko Channel sorry the moral of the
story I guess is if you find a deal that
seems too good to be true it probably is
push it through that ice then we go
through like butter man and I was like
he transfers into the coin
I took an entire semester on heat
transfer but she pushes it of course I
did
that's how engineers students flirt
perfect take a class on heat transfer
exactly how do transfer so much heat
what are you doing up in this cave did
consolidating man I watch off my friends
roaches oh it creeps me out sometimes
what just working up here just being up
here by myself it's dark
hey Carmichael yeah so see that there's
a new film right shorts out apparently
Andrew Kramer did a bunch of the effects
on this one right there
oh dang it out keep clicking on the
wrong thing come on damn one more thing
this wall is the same thing snow or
anything
great lady
eyes are getting dried out I can't close
three special tutorial
[Music]
fire looks good sounds great
legitimate l-like a movie to me so good
work as I was go check out film right
watch their news short it's called ghost
house check the one before that's called
chainsaw
they're giving away like forty thousand
dollars worth of stuff like filmmaking
equipment like comically even uses like
all their uh or film music and stuff
anytime I like stressing out just like
really totally also Josh I'm waiting for
you to get one of these dude today we're
going up to Simi Valley to see the
lovely Smith family ranch we're gonna do
what's called a tech Scout we're gonna
meet with the stunt coordinator mr.
Robert dill we're gonna go over
choreography we're gonna do some camera
tests we're gonna talk about art the
term tech scout can mean a number of
different things depending on what the
shoot requires sometimes you can go on a
tech scout and it can be all about
lighting and power and production
resources and how to get something into
a location and then successfully set it
up and leave because this shoot is all
based from a first-person perspective
this shoot is all about the choreography
that we do with stuntmen in order to
walk ourselves through the scene on the
day snakes just gonna watch the big
watch okay thanks go ahead corridor does
does the dopest [ __ ] and can do it you
know with the style involved and that
was our goal was just to have
talented really [ __ ] just impressive
people who are just passionate and
that's why corridors with us today we
are blocking out the scene kind of
getting all my friends into position and
we're gonna kind of roll through it and
see what happens
so maker just called me his friend
mm-hmm I made it just called me his
friend so come up and start rushing
really this way I'm gonna be a standing
oh did you see this coming
that's coming down there's like runs
around everybody god it's going well
well tricky I think the rest of its
gonna go smooth tricky because the
person was the camera on their face
can't see what the recording it just
won't work
there's also surprising to learn that
going slow looks really really fast in
first person on the day we're going to
be like 10 actors here and stick mention
it's kind of a big scene kind of an
important see both in terms of the
series and in terms of our careers so
you know just wanted to get it right
just want to not mess up hey Bret
Jake needs a Brett oh [ __ ] dude
dude what's up yeah he's up here Jake Oh
what is that power that's just told
America right there boom
it is currently lunchtime and I wanted
to go get some Thai food
and look who's joining us Carmichael on
the blue side boy no the low battery
sound yeah on the remote that should be
enough right let's hope the only
downside to this Trek is that we have to
get off of them to get up on this carb
people oh yeah we should build a ramp
are you hungry yet starving okay done
with lunch time to go back to work so
tasty
[Music]
shooting dirty my I go faster faster
that's more like it